this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armories museum in the uk which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this episode as we've had a ton of
requests for it jonathan is going to be
taking a look at the weaponry of the
halo franchise from the iconic all the
way through to the damn right bazaar so
when you go alien you can go absolutely
completely off the drawing board and do
what you want and this thing classic
halo weapon of course how does it work
goodness knows don't ask me i just do
guns and this is not a gun if you want
to see jonathan's take on halo infinite
make sure to subscribe as he'll be
taking a look at that in a future
episode and if you enjoy this kind of
content make sure to keep an eye out for
our upcoming series loadout a show where
we take a look at the history and impact
of some of the most iconic weapons in
gaming from the m1 garand and the desert
eagle through to the minigun and the
ak-47
naturally jonathan will be making a fair
few appearances over on that show too so
make sure to check that out right let's
take a look at halo
the the payload pistol the magnum always
struck me a little odd i mean my memory
of it is not very magnami
it felt like a standard kind of nine
millimeter sidearm really very radical
looking appearance with that weird uh
knuckle bow trigger guard on it guess
you could use that as a
knuckle duster otherwise there's really
not much point of being on there it
makes the makes what's supposed to be a
compact carry type firearm unnecessarily
bulky and difficult to holster
potentially but this incarnation does
more closely resemble what i think the
inspiration for the magnum might have
been which is the uh volta p99 it's very
far from it especially that first
iteration this this version more so i
mean the red mark on the back of the
slide on the real gun that's the back
end of the striker and is the cocked
indicator that's why it's red on this
it's some sort of i don't know actually
what is on this and we have a textured
on
safety decocker type thing on the side
the whole thing looks more conventional
modern pistol and then in halo 3 we are
back to that bulbous barrel shroud on
the front really not clear what that's
for it would sort of implies itself to
be housing for a laser sight or
something but not aware of any of that
functionality being in the game
okay so um odst is not a game i actually
played i've not seen this incarnation of
the pistol before almost more subdued
and more modern looking the the trigger
guard the giant trigger guard is played
down a little bit some sort of laser
light module under the barrel which yeah
this this doesn't look far off from
certain modern pistols and it's meant to
be suppressed very suppressed because it
has the hollywood pew pew sound but
there's no visible suppressor on there
now since this came out there's the
silencerco maxim 9 which is a very cool
looking sci-fi
pistol that's real
which has a completely contained
suppressor system that you can change
the length of in all sorts that has the
bulk to compensate for the lack of
length if that makes sense here we've
got a very short pistol
without the bulk in the front of the gun
to accommodate expanding gases and make
it quiet so there must be some kind of
sci-fi technology going on here to make
it so quiet which raises the question
why wouldn't you have that on all of
your guns and all the other firearms and
they should all be suppressed integrally
automatically because why wouldn't you
other than video game logic which says
that your suppressed bullets hurt less
i would guess the most iconic halo
weapon for most people the assault rifle
some may disagree although that might be
partly because of the tangential
connection to the fn f-2000 assault
rifle anyone that's seen the f2000
before which of course is most of the
fps gaming community they immediately
make the connection to this and in fact
um in the art of halo the book
apparently chap in charge of the halo
bible the law around the game and who
was like the go-to guy for the guns of
the original game as well comments on
the
the resemblance and said yeah you
absolutely agrees it looks very similar
i think similar is fair enough in this
case absolutely true he definitely
didn't see
the f-2000 before the assault rifle was
designed because this rifle did not
debut on the international
arms fair circuit until march of 2001
and if you know anything about video
game development you know that the game
and most of its weapons would have been
there by then because halo didn't launch
until what uh fall of that same year now
what also backs up the idea that they're
just convergent design
is
really it's not that similar to be
honest the general silhouette absolutely
but in detail you know the action is
conventional on this it has an ejection
port it has a cocking handle mounted on
the left side where you might expect it
to be it doesn't have the long cocking
handle slot on the front left the lower
profile of the gun is very different
it's close enough that it made the guy
responsible or partly responsible for
its design at least raise his own
eyebrow at it so we have to acknowledge
it but it is not based on the f2000
the thing that's always confused me
about the halo universe the one thing
that stuck out like a sore thumb for me
is the use of explicitly 7.62 by 51 nato
ammunition for weapons like the assault
rifle i
get a does not compute reaction to that
i'm afraid the weapons are so visibly
different and advanced and yet we're
still using 762 nato not only that it's
i believe it's ex specifically m118 or
m118 special ball 762 ammo and reading
that you might think oh it's some hyper
advanced 500 years hence loading of 762
nato somehow they've got amazing new
propellant armor-piercing sub-caliber
projectile who knows and they're just
using 762 as the parent case
no m118 was developed pretty early on
60s
as a match grade round for snipers to
use so all it is is more accurate than
standard machine gun grade 760 by 51. so
it's not even a future loading of 762.
it's like everything else moved on
ammunition technology stayed exactly
what not only stayed where it was went
back in time
this is pretty out there compared to the
conventional
firearms of halo it's also a combination
weapon we have a number of combination
weapons in the royal armouries
collection going back to the 16th
century um we have a really bizarre
match lock wheel lock gun axe thing if
you have a look on our collections
database you'll you should be able to
find that with some of those words
nothing like this but a blade combined
with a fairly large caliber gun which is
what this is if we set the blade aside
for a moment the gun part is pretty
reminiscent of the 20 millimeter
neo pup portable cannon
portable automatic candle self-loading
cannon and a giant sword
why not it's a sci-fi franchise
the classic dual wield of the smg's
remember rightly and from what i'm
seeing on screen these are meant to be
caseless which just makes me all the
more confused that we're still using
normal present-day ammunition in other
guns in the future the recoil is
tremendous on these things now
cumulatively pistol caliber firearms
yeah of course they can really push you
back if you don't resist them in any way
you know you'll be pointing at the thing
at the sky as we saw there but of course
master chief is sort of bio-engineered
and an absolute seven foot unit
so
i would be surprised like really should
probably look like arnie shooting a an
uzi one-handed or something it shouldn't
really rise at all just just twisting
the wrists down should be enough to keep
the thing
on target but of course for gameplay
reasons it's very fast firing if you
don't induce some vertical dispersion
whole magazine is going to go on the
target and you you know you've got a
game-winning weapon
the so-called battle rifle this thing is
an anomaly so we have our we have our
assault rifle that's actually firing a
battle rifle cartridge 762 nato 7.62 by
51 millimeters and then we have this
battle rifle which we might expect to be
firing an even more powerful cartridge
and indeed the bullet is a higher
diameter larger diameter 9.5 millimeters
but the case length is only 40
millimeters so that's substantially less
than 762 nato it's the same case length
as the um 50 caliber handgun round in
the game so that doesn't really make
much sense unless the term battle rifle
and the role of battle rifle is
different and in fact the game seems to
or the series seems to bear this out
because i think most iterations of the
battle rifle certainly this one fire in
three round burst mode so what we're
getting here is if anything lower
velocity but a bigger heavier bullet and
three of them at once what doesn't
really enjoy with that take that it's
maybe like a more specialist take on
assault rifle is the fact that it does
tend to come with a scope and you do
find yourself using it as a dmr as the
name would imply a battle rifle so it
doesn't really fit current doctrine why
should it it's 500 years in the future
of course when you go um outside of the
human future if you like and you start
looking at well either other human
cultures or alien cultures you've got a
lot more artistic freedom to come up
with know what might they have developed
as a projectile weapon so this is
something very um unusual this thing
with its twin
curved bayonets effectively i think you
you'd need you have to sort of justify
that in some way and i guess like a
warrior culture that is always wanting
the ability to hit people in the face
with knives is about the only
justification for having not one but two
permanently attached bayonets
so when you go alien you can go
absolutely completely off the drawing
board and do what you want and this
thing you know classic halo weapon of
course how does it work goodness knows
the crystal shard things on top that you
slot in disappear into the body of the
gun and emerge as blobs of energy i'm
sure there's some kind of a cannon or
fanon explanation for how the hell that
works don't ask me i just do guns and
this is not a gun i mean it's a gun in
the kind of colloquial sense of a weapon
that shoots stuff but it's not a gun in
the technical sense of a tube with
propellant in it that launches a
projectile it's it's an energy weapon
actually this thing's even weirder than
that because you're not putting new
crystals in in order to shoot them out
as energy you just kind of give it a
shake and they regrow
and then they shrink back into the gun
and shoot out so i'm not even sure why
they need to stick out of the housing of
the weapon in the first place so the
closest thing we have today to something
like this would be a gun that shoots
flechettes uh steel or tungsten darts
you can even get pistol rounds believe
it or not that shoot tiny little sharp
tungsten or steel finned darts they need
some kind of stabilization because
they're not going down a rifled barrel
so they usually do have little fins on
the back end of them a bow and arrow has
more in common with a flechette shooting
gun than this has in common with any of
our technology but insofar as it
physically propels a sharp pointy stick
at the enemy it's kind of a form of a
flechette
the chamber's charge
will this bring the cartographer back
online
partially
this type of process the
closest parallel to the magnum pistol
for the humans is the covenant energy
pistol i obviously can't say much very
intelligent on how it might work or
plausibility of that i do think it's
interesting other than its charging up
ability um interesting in the ergonomic
sense of it kind of has a foregrip now
we do we do have for certain fully
automatic pistols the option of a full
grip that clips onto the dust cover rail
closest thing we would have to this
really problem there is you have to kind
of push pull to stabilize the gun you've
got no shoulder stock this doesn't have
a shoulder stop two hands are always
better than one for holding a handgun
though but really you'd be better off
holding both hands at the back on the
pistol grip not one at the front it's
there's gonna be a lot of talk a lot of
waving around but hey this is a mainly
human
holding an alien gun how the hell do you
hold it who knows
so as if to set me straight on the whole
dmr battle rifle quandary here is the
actual dmr which i'd forgotten even
existed it's a big chunky
seemingly pretty high caliber thing it
has a strong family resemblance to the
assault rifle and the battle rifle
they're all bullpups all got the charge
cocking handle in the same place they
all have the same kind of manual of arms
which makes sense that you would want to
keep that consistent across the whole
family the design has a great big gas
tube on the bottom of the barrel which i
think design wise implies something more
powerful but it also has kind of lending
a bit of an lmg appearance other than
the big gas tube and the big muzzle
device is a weird kind of iron sight at
the front which doesn't make a huge
amount of sense to me but yeah it fits
the family slow firing powerful ability
to zoom in with the scope it's just that
relationship between the assault and
battle rifle that i've never fully
clipped with
okay i neither remember nor understand
this weapon so this is a this is a saw
so squad automatic weapon okay and
that's why it has a large drum type high
capacity magazine and it's a high rate
of fire as well so you know ostensibly
that's its niche high volume of fire
it's like an lmg in a normal fps and
then you have the practical head
scratcher of how the heck the magazine
works it's a spin to unlock by the look
of it there's some sort of lug on the
side you spin it round and it drops out
fine but then
when the player fits a new magazine he
has to spin it to lock it into place
fine why doesn't it drop out as soon as
he shoves it in though i would expect
you to have to shove it in and rotate it
to lock that wouldn't be a super
efficient way to have a magazine work
anyway they've tried to do something
different try to add something to the
kind of cannon but i don't think it's
quite as satisfying as the classic
weapons always a problem when you try
and change up the formula though
now that i think about it the halo
shotgun has uh always been a bit weird
it falls into that sci-fi trap of being
a pump action shotgun in the future and
okay we still use pump action shotguns
in in niche military applications
certainly in in police use still but
self-loading shotguns have become so
reliable and affordable i can't see
pumps lasting that much longer for any
kind of official use put it that way
more so than that the the technical
aspects of how this would work are a bit
also a bit confusing so we have the pump
at the bottom as we normally would
normally that would wrap around a
magazine tube and this doesn't have a
box magazine sticking out of it but the
halo shotgun is loaded from the top
which is nice and convenient for for
loading and topping off but how do you
get the rounds pass the barrel of the
gun into the magazine or is the magazine
on the top and the pump is remotely
linked to the magazine tube and so
they're like sandwiching the barrel
that's kind of the only way this can
work in reality of course the mechanics
just haven't been thought through
because why should they be but i like it
when they are
i'll
all right i don't remember what this is
called in the in the game triple
barrelled rotary machine gun or possibly
cannon i'm not actually sure of the
caliber either to be honest encountered
as a turret mounted gun and of course
being an action game the player is able
to pick them up and use them uh predator
style of course what the guy we've got
here is an odst trooper who is not
augmented he's not seven feet tall could
he do this i maybe there's some recoil
like super recoil buffer in there i
don't know um if there is i would expect
that technology to be applied to the
rifles as well and then to have zero
recoil i think we're just fudging it
action movie style to be honest
first strike double kill
double kill
quite a cool massive space rocket
launcher with spinning barrel type tube
launcher things
and a big drum type magazine clip feed
device thing but i don't quite
understand what's going on because it
looks like the top barrel is firing a
rocket shooting a rocket and then the
barrel cluster of two one barrel offset
is then doing a full 360 spin back to
where it started and then firing the
next one so unless what looks like a
second barrel is actually some other
part of the weapon it's actually
single-barreled feeding from the
magazine don't really get this one if
anyone understands how this is supposed
to work please let me know
right so this is actually quite
plausible for a present-day
anti-materiel rifle the 14.5 millimeter
cartridge is um a russian designed very
large caliber round obviously so that
that big caliber still being in use in
the in this this right in the future
makes more sense actually because like
really quite hard to top that with
conventional technology it's uh
self-loading so it's not not hobbled by
being a straight pull bolt action or
something plausible looking design um i
don't imagine that we ever use the bipod
with it though the scope does have the
air of being something sci-fi and
futuristic don't think it has any real
functionality beyond a beyond a modern
scope though
as always have a look in the description
for links to royal armouries
site we've got our own youtube channel
if you haven't found me over there you
might be interested to go and have a
look at that we have ways that you can
donate and support us and what we do
here at the museum but most of all i
hope to see you next week
[Music]
you